Women do not fall for guys just because they have money
Men are convinced that's all any woman wants
when in reality
what any woman really wants is a man that she can build a future with
plenty of woman will tell you that they fall for guys based on these qualities
and none of them involve money
Women fall for guys who have these qualities,
number one: they're funny
they have a good sense of humour
they can make any woman laugh
if you as a man have a good sense of humour
you can date woman far out of your league
take Pete Davidson for example
No. 2: if you're charismatic
woman love when a guy is charming and charismatic
they fall in love for you for your personality
Women are drawn to men who light up a room when they walk in it
3: if you're trustworthy
women seek out men who they can trust
you make a girl feel like she's the only girl for you
then you'll have her forever
4 if you're dependable
women fall in love with guys that they can depend on in a time of need
maybe they need a help change a tire or whatever it may be
if you can help them resolve problems then that's what they fall in love for
five women fall in love with men who praise and admire her
meaning you're completely smitten with her
if she feels special to you
then it's over
she's falling in love with you
Never have I met a friend, family member,
any female acquaintance say that they fell in love with the man for his money
Women do not fall in love with men for their money
and thinking that is ridiculous